With work, study or any table full of stress it will be difficult to find time or energy
For an extra round in the bedroom - to practice love - but can science have a solution to our sexual problems?
Maybe he can ...
Sexual desire in women and men is controlled by hormones, when it drives you
Something to be "stimulated", sends both brain and nervous system signals to the pelvic area, causing
Aneurysms, heart rate will increase, your brain will release hormones:
Norepinephrine, dopamine and other neurotransmitters
Your body will understand that you are having fun.
Man has long tried to improve this biological response throughout history. Unfortunately
There is no scientific evidence in popular culture that oysters or chocolate
Or other so-called "sexual arousal stimuli" will make you sexually motivated, Viagra can prolong erection
Contrary to the popular belief that it will make you feel. Viagra works
Slowly to inhibit a certain enzyme and thus will increase blood flow to the penis and it works on
Peripheral nervous system only. So taking a blue pill will not increase libido
An erection will not occur without prior stimulation. Needless to say, it has no effect on women.
But it turns out that scientists have mistakenly found a new secret about sex ...
During the attempts to create industrialization agents, scientists studied melanocortin
- A specific protein in the brain that can control the coloration of the skin - when injecting ten milligrams of an industrial version of it called melanotane 2
In male, an erection will occur immediately and without stimulation
And will remain for eight hours continuous accompanied by nausea and vomiting, at 2.5 mg
The erection lasted from two to three hours with little nausea but when the dose was 1.25 mg
The males were sexually aroused and had a steady erection without any nausea, from the sudden
It has been approved by the government drug to be taken by nasal spray "stimulation by sniffing" any one?
Moreover, the drug works on females as well.
When a female rat was injected along with some methylated beta-estradiol 3 benzoate hormones
Along with progesterone, females increased their jumping, throwing love arrows and moving their ears in front of their male counterparts.
All these signs are designed to create sexual desire and to invite males to have sex.
But before you go on to find this magical miraculous love you have to learn
That it has not been ratified or legislated anywhere in the world yet, anyway
One of its derivatives, called pralmanotide, is currently being tested in human clinical trials as a possible treatment.
When there is a large sexual deficit such as failure to occur sexual desire in females.
When the main event occurs directly in the central nervous system it works on both sexes.
Gender.
You can eat avocados, oysters or chocolate as sources of nutrition only ... and let the science take over sex.
Sex.
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting this episode and giving you a free audio book
Of your choice at audible.com/asap. Audible is a leading provider of audiobooks
Over 150,000 downloadable titles across all types of literature. We recommend the book
"A human being: medicine and what matters in the end" that deals with how the drug
Not only improve life, but the process of its end. You can download this audio book
Or another of your choice, for free, at audible.com/asap. With a subscription you get one book for free
In month! Special thanks to the audio for making these videos possible!
Subscribe to get more weekly flag videos!